[Music]  time runs differently in this place  at night the moon upstages the Sun  [Music]  how long have you been standing there  for  [Music]  we wanted to be somewhere  just not with humans I think it can feel  wild out here  the London is the jungle we left it  together in fact it was here in Topanga  the Florence and I decided to settle but  this house it's not my house these  cloves not my clothes  [Music]  these hands  Benjamin and Florence it's so great to  have you on the show do you in a  relationship one is always chasing the  other somehow  [Music]  living in solitude makes you confront  things some things you could otherwise  forget and some you can't  can you ever know what they're thinking  I mean what they're really thinking  we're too close  I can't focus  [Music]  no man can be an island yeah what's my  time the boundary let's do it again  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you